The relationship between these two functions we've been talking about has a
special name. They are inverse functions of one another. As I said before, just
looking at these equations, you might not have any idea right off the bat that
these functions are inverses. To help make that more clear immediately, there's
a special notation we can use. Let's say that we have a function that we're
calling f. Then if f has an inverse, we can write that inverse like this, f
with a little negative 1 up here to the right. Now we have to be super careful,
when we use this notation. This does not, I repeat, does not mean 1 over f. The
negative 1 here is not an exponent. You read this as f inverse, not f to the
negative 1. To make sure that we're keeping everything straight. Now, let's
suppose that f, in this case, is f of x equals 3x minus 1. Right away, we can
plug in values for x to figure out different points on the line. I'll just pick
out a few for right now. We have 0 comma negative 1. 1 comma 2, and negative 1
comma negative 4. We don't know the equation for the inverse of f quite yet,
but we do know that we can denote it like this, and we actually know quite a
bit more information about this, because of these points here. Based on the
information we have about the function f, what points do we know will lie on f
inverse? Below each of these points that lie on f, Please write the
corresponding points on f inverse.